publicaré mis declaraciones de impuestos
contra la voluntad de mis abogados
cuando ella publique los 33 mil correos
electrónicos que fueron eliminados del
líder el misterio alrededor de las
declaraciones de impuestos de donald
trump viene desde hace varios años ahora
el diario estadounidense the new york
times' asegura haber tenido acceso a
información de dichas declaraciones del
magnate de las últimas dos décadas el
informe revela que trump no pagó
impuestos federales sobre la renta en 10
de los últimos 15 años ya que reportó
que sus empresas perdieron más dinero
del que ganaron y en 2016 año en el que
resultó electo pago al fisco tan sólo
750 dólares también una cifra similar en
2017 la investigación revela además que
el presidente estaría bajo presión al
enfrentar deudas por cientos de millones
de dólares
trump rechazó los hallazgos del 'new
york times'
son noticias totalmente inventadas y
falsas pasamos por las mismas historias
podrías haberme hecho las mismas
preguntas hace cuatro años tuve que
litigar esto y hablar de ello
noticias totalmente falsas en realidad
pague impuestos y lo verán pronto en mis
declaraciones de impuestos pero están
bajo auditoría
la bancada demócrata expresó su
indignación donald trump es un mentiroso
un tramposo y un hombre de negocios
deshonesto pero también se está
aprovechando un sistema desigual roto y
corrupto que está diseñado para que las
personas como él hagan lo que hizo con
moción de conmoción es donald trump
autoproclamado multimillonario recibió
un reembolso de 72,9 millones de dólares
del servicio de recaudación de impuestos
mientras que no pagó ni un centavo en
impuestos federales sobre la renta en 10
de los últimos 15 años
donald trump es el único presidente de
la historia moderna de eeuu en haberse
rehusado a publicar sus declaraciones
fiscales y actualmente enfrenta
investigaciones por posible fraude ante
la fiscalidad de manhattan un nuevo
escándalo justo antes del primer debate
entre el trump y el demócrata joe bailén
previsto para el martes
[Aplausos]